identify and briefly describe
the information technology required by
this teleconferencing system
okay so i was kind of looking for a few
main things okay and even if you had
three items like three marks three items
okay um if you missed some critical
items and i'll tell you the main one
which most people missed
um you you couldn't get the full marks
because it showed you missed a crucial
piece of information
okay so what kinds of things shout out
the obvious ones to me
camera camera thank you computer okay
stop baby now we can say you can't say
computer computer's not wrong
okay but we may i think i mentioned this
in the last last exam okay
computer computers are everywhere you're
always going to say computer and it
doesn't give you
it doesn't for me i can't see that you
understand anything about the situation
if you said computer if all you said was
computer i'd give you zero
okay because you could say computer
about any different system okay what is
it about the computer that we actually
want
for a teleconferencing system a screen
ah thank you
good morning yes screen
both are fine but that fine if you
really want to go all the way you should
really say visual display
unit but i'm not gonna be okay you know
it's not a competition all right so you
got something to capture
you got something to um view right but
so far we've only got the visual element
microphone and of course it's got it's
it's counterpart which is the speakers
a lot of people forgot speakers a lot of
people forgot speakers now
i'll tell you right now i didn't i
didn't deduct
for for lacking speakers okay because if
you generally people say mike
and that shows you've got it you've
taken into account that there's okay
there's
there's audio here and i've got it you
know but you should you should think
like bread and butter
okay um oreos and milk like they should
be
they're two sides of the same coin okay
yeah
don't do it anyway okay now um that's a
nice basic setup but there's a big
glaring
hole
okay yeah that high speed internet we've
already mentioned
um and we you do need to to say it here
but i would say that this is still in
the same
category of objects as all the
some rest yeah software thank you okay
this was the big one
i'm going to put it in capital letters
okay so all of this is hardware
right now you need specific software and
some of it like was named
in part c even right but generally
speaking
um it's a big deal
for a computer to be able to send sorry
let's start again
to collect and then encode and then send
and then
decode uh all this data is being
captured by all of this stuff
okay so this software is actually very
sophisticated it has to do a lot of very
specific things okay
we sort of live in the age of of youtube
and google plus hangouts and it's like
yeah
computers can do video of course they
can do video
rubbish okay it's a really big task for
software this specific software designed
for it
you didn't have to say what it was you
had to say the software was involved in
some way
okay so there was kind of like two marks
here and this is a critical mark that a
lot of people dropped
okay so think about um go back to
like in some ways this is like you know
the system diagram
right that was usually the eight marks
and like the prelim course okay so
you've got what do you got you got
purpose
um processors and then you've got
data participants and information
technology right
so this question is really just doing
that bit down the bottom
okay and back in the prelim course still
people forgot to put software in this
okay so please make sure like you
put like big red notes that information
technology must
must include software